Alright, now that we have the frame and we added the content, we interlinked everything,
we are going to do the on-page SEO.
Let's start with the page title.
So the page title is, I have our Bentonville Concrete website up here.
The page title is what comes up when you hover at the very top of the website.
So we like to keep the page title between 50 to 60 characters and to add that on Weebly,
so we select, we're going to do this for every page except for the contact as page.
We are going to do it but it's not going to be to SEO because the contact page, we don't
really care for the ranking as much as the other pages, we don't add content, it's just
a way for people to submit a form.
So you're going to click on pages, you're going to click on the home one, right here
under and don't get it confused with the page name, that's just the home, go into SEO settings
and up here in the page title, we usually like to do service comma service comma location.
So for our website it would be, and again you can pick the keywords that are most representing
of your business, the ones that rank the most are the ones with the most volume in search
that you probably want to have for the home page.
So concrete contractors and then concrete, we could even do company, Queen Creek is a
pretty long location, so let's see if, and then make sure you add the state, let's copy
this and ward counter, okay, we usually use the wardcounter.net, it's pretty easy, okay
Okay, we're 55 characters, so we're good, and then let's do the ones for the other service
pages, I have a stamped concrete right here, so obviously the page title for that is going
to be stamped concrete, stamped concrete, we can do like decorative concrete, you want
to really pay attention to how you're spelling things, make sure you're putting everything
in the word counter too, to make sure you're not going over 60 characters, let's do concrete
driveway, let me see what we did here, okay, I'm actually just going to put it in here
so I don't have to copy and paste it, so let's do concrete driveway, concrete dollars, okay,
that works, let's copy and paste it, pretty easy, especially once you have your keyword
extended and you know exactly what you want to target, and then let's do concrete patio,
the first keyword should be fairly simple, if it is too long for the location and you
don't fit two keywords, just pick one keyword if that's the case, it's always better to
do less than to go over, okay, so could do walkway or sidewalk, really again just look
at your keyword list and the ones with the highest volume that are related to the content
that you're going to add to the page is what you want to put, so definitely if you have
a homepage for concrete patio, you definitely want to put concrete patio in the page title,
and then the second keyword I would probably do whatever it is that has a high search and
you're going to talk about in that page, concrete patio, and make sure you publish, you need to
publish everything, and then for the contact page we usually like to keep it simple, so I would
probably just put contact, Queen Creek, concrete, and then make sure you publish, save everything,
and you're done.